Approach.
Open your arms up wide like a proud eagle...
...and then tilt your head in whichever direction you feel comfortable.
Slightly raise your arm in the direction of your tilted head.
This will indicate your intention to your partner...
...and prevent any head to head collisions.
Finally, glide in slowly and confidently.
The squeeze.
Maintaining your body in a semirigid manner...
...will indicate to your friend that you are in control of the embrace.
Make sure your arms are not like wet noodles...
...but rather like the warm branches of a firm oak.
Turn your head out at this point and stare into the horizon.
The pat.
The pat is the staple of any good man hug.
Put your own creative spin on the pat.
Do you like to use a fist or an openhanded karate chop?
Whatever the gesture, make sure it is firm, confident, and filled with spirit.